nathalie baye bonsoir le film s'appelle
donc les sentiments et à l'image jeu
sans doute de la vraie vie comme disait
nathalie était dans le reportage ces
sentiments-là sons sont très complexes
est ce que c'est la vie de couple en
fait qui est si complexe que ça
moi je crois que la vie tout court est
complexe mais à vie de couple et a
particulièrement complexe avec des
moments merveilleux des moments
difficiles est ce que c'est ce que
j'aime dans ce film c'est que s'il n'y a
pas de c'est la vie tout le temps il n'y
a pas de il n'y a pas une vision
négative ou méchante c'est quelque chose
c'est un film très généreux je trouve
alors les questions que se posent les
personnages sont universels l'amour
est-il univers celle justement éternel
la trahison est elle évitable
vous avez des réponses vous mais non non
on n'a pas de réponses à beaucoup de
questions n'a pas de réponse mais mais
en tout cas ce que toutes ces question
qu'on peut se poser ça nous empêche pas
d'avoir envie toujours d'aimer et de
tomber amoureux alors carole votre
personnage est à la fois drôle elle est
fragile c'est une femme délaissée trompé
par son médecin de marie mais elle est
également généreuse et pleine de vie
c'est ce qui la sauve ce oui parce
qu'elle n'est pas triste elle et c'est
une femme qui est curieuse de tout qui a
de la bienveillance qui fait des petites
boom tout seul qui picolent un peu trop
qui fume beaucoup mais qui et qui aime
son mari qui aime ses enfants et qui n'a
pas de il n'y a pas qu'elle n'y a rien
de mesquin chez elle ferme un très très
beau personnage vous parlez de la
cigarette elle fume beaucoup les
médecins fument aussi beaucoup dans le
film fut bissé le
nouvel acte de rébellion aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas si c'est un acte de rébellion
des cages faut pas encore un film si
vite sur ce point là non pas du tout
mais c'est un mais je sais pas donc
fumée oui fument du film voilà il fume
et l'autre le thème principal c'est donc
l'adultère synthe m en fait très
fréquents au cinéma il inspiré de très
nombreux réalisateurs qu'est ce qui fait
de ces sentiments film à part sur un
sujet pourtant le très fréquemment
utilisé le traitement c'est le talent de
noémie lvovsky qui est une km où je
trouve que c'est une jeune réalisatrice
extrêmement doué et cela jean pierre
bacri isabelle carré enfin il m'a dit
propos moi quand on a lu le scénario on
a dit oui tout de suite parce qu'il ya
un point de vue on raconte une histoire
d'amour classique mais avec un point de
vue extrêmement particulier plein
d'humour et plein de générosité plein de
bon sens en même temps c'est pas s'est
il n'y a pas de vulgarité c'est extra
payant passe de la drôlerie à l'émotion
avec je trouve comme ça d'une manière
assez abrupte alors nathalie baye ces
dernières années tous les films et ils
ont été nombreux dans lesquelles vous
avez joué ont rencontré un très grand
succès vous avez d'ailleurs obtenu le
prix d'interprétation à venise pour une
liaison pornographique un rôle
magnifique mais aujourd'hui certains de
vos camarades et je pense notamment
francis huster que j'ai entendu cette
semaine sur paris première le recto
verso estime que vous avez tous montré
que vous avez tous prouvé en tant
qu'actrice et que vous devriez désormais
de passer de l'autre côté de la caméra
une deuxième carrière de réalisatrice à
l'image de nicole garcia par exemple ça
ça vous tenterait bah écoutez je sais
pas pour le moment j'y pense pas et puis
tout simplement je sais pas si j'en sais
capable j'aime beaucoup jouer je me
rends compte pour vous
avec qui vous avez fait le conservatoire
il pense que je je sais pas s'il savait
c'est autre chose tout moi je suis en ce
moment très gâté on propose des bobos
les jeux les six passes de l'autre côté
de la caméra on peut sans plus oui parce
qu'on vous voit actuellement
à la fiche de france boutique avec karin
viard et françois cluzet c'est une
histoire la très très drôle on s'amuse
tout bref oui c'était très drôle pour
moi je fais une toute petite
participation parce que tony est une
réalisatrice que j'aime beaucoup mais
c'est un film très drôle
merci beaucoup en tout cas un athée
l'hybride est revenue sur le plateau du
19h je rappelle que les sentiments
sortent mercredi